Try to pause the video and figure it out
on your own.
So what I like to do is
I like to write down what they tell us
and then think about what might make sense.
So, first of all we have Emeka.
They tell us that Emeka got a 17
when she spinned the wheel.
So Emeka got a 17. This is Emeka's number
right over here, she got a 17.
Now, what about Tom?
They tell us Tom got a number
that was 15 more than Emeka's number
So, did Tom get a higher number or a
lower number than Emeka?
Well, Tom's number is 15 more than Emeka's.
So, it's going to be a larger number.
So, it's going to be Emeka's number plus 15.
So, 15 more than 17.
So, it's Emeka's number,
and it's going to be 15 more than that.
So, notice 15 more than Emeka's number
Well, Emeka's number is 17.
15 more than that is going to be 17 + 15.
So what's 17 + 15 going to be?
So, I can calculate it right over here.
So, I'll line them up.
So, 17 is 1 ten and 7 ones
and 15 is 1 ten and 5 ones
and I'm going to add.
So let's first look at the ones place.
So, 7 ones + 5 ones, that's going to be
12 ones.
But, 12 ones is the same thing as 1 ten
and 2 ones.
So, I could write the 2 ones down here
and then I would write the 1 ten up here.
Another way you could think about it is
I just carried the 1.
7 + 5 is 12, I wrote the 2 down here
and I carried the 1.
But what I'm really saying is
look 7 + 5 is 12, 12 is 2 ones and 1 ten.
And now I just add up the tens
1 ten + 1 ten + 1 ten is 3 tens
So it's 32.
So, Tom got a 32.
And you should always check to see if
that makes sense.
It says that Tom got a number that was 15
more than Emeka's number.
Well, is 32, 15 more than Emeka's number?
Is 32, 15 more than 17?
Sure it is, because 17 + 15 is 32.
That's how we figured it out.